Хочу наголосити що нами протягом
останніх двох тижнів прийнято рішення
профінансувати 150 млн грн за рахунок
власних коштів для виготовлення
суперсучасного засобу радіоелектронної
боротьби і я дуже щасливий бо ми пройшли
перше Випробування
ее дослідницького зразка і ми посадили
перші два в бойових умовах російських
безпілотника які координували ланцети це
свято для мене Хочу наголосити що нами
протягом останніх двох тижнів прийнято
рішення профінансувати 150 млн грвень за
рахунок власних коштів для виготовлення
суперсучасного засобу радіоелектронної
боротьби і я дуже щасливий бо ми пройшли
перше Випробування
е дослідницького зразка і ми посадили
перші два в бойових умовах російських
безпілотника які координували